una crisis política que corre el riesgo
de convertirse en una guerra total
estas imágenes de trípoli la capital
libia muestran las secuelas de los
sangrientos enfrentamientos del sábado
entre las milicias enfrentadas
una de ellas apoya al gobierno de unidad
nacional reconocido internacionalmente y
a su líder abdel mayid beiba y la otra
defiende la administración rival
dirigida por el primer ministro fathi
bachagha con sede en el este del país el
humo envolvió el cielo durante la noche
mientras las explosiones sacudían varios
distritos de la ciudad mientras el
ministro de sanidad del país afirmaba
que decenas de personas habían muerto y
otras decenas habían resultado heridas
en los combates
no vamos a renunciar a nuestro país esta
gente horrible quiere destruir nuestro
país la gente de adentro y de afuera
tiene planes para destruirnos
baby acusó a by haga de cumplir sus
amenazas de tomar trípoli por la fuerza
la misión de las naciones unidas en
libia pidió el cese inmediato de las
hostilidades mientras que el embajador
estadounidense en trípoli condenó la
violencia e instó a una mediación
facilitada por la onu el consejo
municipal de libia también denunció los
enfrentamientos las instituciones de la
sociedad civil de trípoli condenan
enérgicamente los enfrentamientos
armados en la ciudad y responsabilizan a
las partes participantes derramar sangre
civil e intimidar y destruir la
propiedad privada y pública
libia ha estado en crisis desde los
levantamientos de 2011 que derrocaron al
gobernante coronel muamar gadafi pero a
pesar de esto había disfrutado de una
relativa tranquilidad durante los
últimos dos años